Now let's look at a third property.
Is it invariant to image scale?
That is, now the object has different
scales in the multiple images.
This can be looked at by again just
taking a simple example like this.
So I have two objects here or
two elements.
As you can notice, both of them are the
same except this is much smaller and
this is much larger.
Now, here what becomes
interesting is what
resolution am I looking at information.
So, if for example, if I'm looking,
this is the size of the window I'm
looking at and this is the size of
the window I'm looking at, well nothing
directly would compare to those.
And, depending again what aspects of
these regions am I kind of scaling and
observing, I would have
problems with this.
This, of course, would be
a perfect match at just this size.
And there is no similarity at this
window for this whole region.
But as I said, this basically is
the same object just scaled up.
So what I would need
is a different size.
This of course in this
detector will be a corner.
This will not be at this window
size detected as a corner.
In fact, they will all be listed
as edges, as you would expect.
So of course this suggests that
Harris Detector is not invariant
to image scale.
So what can we do about it?